yeah the compass does anyone want to
make a toast
all right so why I was gonna talk about
his like marine set symposium and
symposiums started out as drinking
parties so if you think about symposia
today if I invite you to symposium which
is supposedly I'm sorry what do you have
in mind you think of sampling what do
you think my idea actually coming from
Italy we are closest to Greece so what I
remember about symposium is drinking
party where anybody can bring in new
ideas to the table and it
EDI is discussed by everybody why
everybody's drinking today
which just makes you jittery and then
you have to sit for an hour and
hopefully it's interesting hopefully
it's something where
you know people are coming in they've
got something to contribute but I know
I've been to my share suppose you get
one particularly if they're after dinner
you really so the question is how do we
go from something like what you're
describing people getting together
drinking talking about ideas which was
the classic suppose yet two of these
these admittedly rather boring academic
affairs what I'd like to talk about is
what what the Greek symposium would like
so I think we all have some pictures of
those and talk about some of what we
would call the literary monument so for
example Aristotle action wrote a
something will happen
if there are other literary monuments
one of the key themes that you see
coming up over and over again in
symposium literary is something that I
call moderation
okay why do that so drinking
that's a pretty definite ideas
and then we'll talk about how we wound
up
stilted Sentai conference
then
bring some clothes here
this also did catch every culture
these drinking parties
they were popular
and these plants
the increases
yeah it wouldn't be pissed
my
they criticize each other
love inside
to the other
more or less
we know what they were drinking who were
they
they were drinking an extremely strong
wine more constant to her and the one
that we are drinking nowadays so they
used dealer wait to meet all the water
for Zach would make it more pleasant to
drink yes
turkey actually talks about this the
same
drink that stretch not four but three or
five let's see if they walk it maybe I'm
supposed to have three drinks or five
drinks not for drinks but there's
something I'm lucky about one that
actually added a portion to fix so they
have this very strong line and they and
the proportion of four was one part wine
the three parts water and they
considered that that's a little bit too
dilute boots are Jack uses that's good
for life when you're judging
the proportion of five was two parts
lines and three parts water so that's
what that getting pretty strong for this
chemistry right then the proportion of
three is this two parts water to one for
wine and that was seen as a little
weaker but it's still good enough to
have time
so we're drinking wine usually they
would have a dinner before the dinner is
not the main fun as matters back then of
funds it will do any facts about them
having the dinner in silence not saying
anything the whole time they're eating
until this this guy shows up who's kept
a meeting well Howard this be different
than our own dinner parties worth
breaking pounds
what's up
toki defense ID we hang out
not that now they write weekly schedule
we're gonna have a symposium global
order you would get some people that you
you newer on the ball in selection and
bring them with
on the street what they didn't they
didn't usually have the beam worked out
ahead of time and anybody
that's not the distinguishing
characteristic that cancer
think about a power sitting right now is
this how they would have a symposium
what do you know of ancient Greek having
having fun leisure
one person
yeah speaking in important
there might be inserted during during
part of the day what they would say okay
not suspicions for them to give a speech
this person's a little screwed I didn't
order that
well no didn't Plato's symposium there
are speeches and these person does give
a speech there is a person in charge but
they have to do more with like how much
wine people not something they weren't
like the master of ceremonies I'm
thinking more about like the fact of
your city
on what catches yes everyone was laying
on couches that's how they ate to maybe
have tables this goes all the way back
to the Maritimes the Greeks and the
Romans pick this up later they thought
it a lie set the chairs laid out and
spend the whole night on one actually
they would share the captures with a lot
of discussion of Plato's symposium about
who's sitting next to me missing out on
sitting next to the attractive person
anything else
yes they were actually held in the men's
section these were always holding
somebody's big house so there'd be a
men's section of the house and at least
Athenian society Spartan society was a
little bit better towards women and
Athenian society but Athenian society
had a very rigid gender separation and
so there there might be some women at
the symposium that they would be
entertainers wives wives would be doing
something else
as a matter of fact I'm forgetting his
name but there's one character in Zen
upon symposium that actually gets made
fun of because he wants to get home
so these tended to be all-male affairs
you can see the real contrast between
what we call symposia today or even what
we call dinner good for is a good form
at a dinner party to just invite that
those of you are etiquette that makes
sense
we probably wouldn't enjoy that sort of
party enjoy I believe we tend to mix
them right the ancient Greeks have
different conceptions now what they
would do is start drinking they would
have that that fortified wine just very
strong wine mix it together start
drinking pour out some libations and
start talking and in some of the
symposia that we have it's very
formulaic now so and so it's going to
get a speech now so it's going to get
the speech and others they're just sort
of records of conversation and one of
the things that we see happening in
these quite a bit is people messing this
is actually a problem supposing laws we
don't have those as literary monuments
will you know about that because in the
things that we have there's precautions
about what these cattle people drink too
much the person who's in charge of that
if somebody who has a bad temper it was
too strict
it was too lenient because everybody
will get upset or won't get drunk enough
or will get too drunk and it'll
degenerate so there's a sense of what
you measure measure and moderation so
any any questions or comments or things
like that at this
well
maybe we're people relying on I mean
effective
in the symposia that we kept records of
there's no you know freaking out
sexual activity very well how about the
unit's Xenophon symposium it's not the
participants it's the entertainers a
young young woman and a young man and
they're supposed to represent Ariadne
and missus
watching
there's no did did historical symposia
which we don't have records of ever
break down into that sort of thing
probably
more often we do know that some broke
down into drawers people couldn't get
along with each other at the very game
and they are talking a lot about the but
erotic cop and identify any other yeah
so it could be anything ranging from the
quality of the horses that they own and
how to tell whether their horse is a
good horse to issues in what they call
natural philosophy at the time which
tended to be things like why is you know
why is the sea salty or why does salt
and salt water seem to dry quicker than
drive a lot of physical problems which
seem kind of screw them to questions
like what is beauty who's more beautiful
thinking about each other's ways of life
and comparing them local politics these
are the things that we know about the
literary what would took place and
others symposium we don't really know
but they weren't you know these were
occasions for having a good time
oftentimes symposia would happen go to
go back to the schedule and they would
be scheduled often after somebody had
done something great Agathon wins the
contest for tragedies
a young man is just coming out into
Athenian society there like a debutante
ball
women
Jennifer airplanes
but they wouldn't say well we need to
discuss this important matter of
statements get your home
really
well
so the ones that we have that's more
than this [ __ ]
thank you it's pretty high level
philosophy Xenophon's there's a lot more
back and forth zucchini doesn't but they
are debating important topics of what
way of life is about they're not just
sort of talking on the rear
Zana funds is usually regarded as less
philosophically this is actually a good
transition point to talk about suppose
that we had and the documents that
unfortunately down so we we have Plato's
symposium and people tend to read that
most often in philosophy classes of the
literature classes
Ellen is the most philosophical they're
giving eye level discussions what is the
nature of love it
zennith identified as another student of
Socrates and he gives us a description
of the symposium that took place in
which Socrates is again one of the main
characters but there's other people
involved
we know that Aristotle wrote a piece
called the symposium we don't know
anything about it because most of
Aristotle's works of actually we know
that's an unfortunate thing
Epicurus he wrote a symposium that one
if we get you would actually we don't
have it you would probably disappointed
that the Kuras had nothing to do with
epicureanism as we think about it today
that would be more another guy in
antiquity communist difference we tend
to think of epicurean as sort of
debauchery or high-level food and wine
to the plan it didn't mean that
Epicurus was off or eating the simplest
food possible hanging out in the garden
with your friends and talking about the
nature of the universe to the strategy
from death so one thing that we do know
about at the curiousness symposium is
that they did discuss a topic that some
people thought they should when should
people have sex
when when is the best time they actually
get together in town sense and Epicurus
does the answer was hardly up well that
might be a little surprising a lot of
the ancient Greeks had this idea that it
was that that sex is actually harmful
for the male body we had a limited
supply of energy and you better not use
it off the Epicureans were animus they
believed that everything was reducible
to physical structures and they thought
that most times of the day we're not
good for sex the sex is going to shake
up the body to begin with you know eat
and drinking and things like that fools
are already shaking up your body you
want to keep the body is calling this
place so what we do know about the
Karaca symposium is it might have been
kind of prudish and import some of you
may know of another literary document
that is telling something sort of like a
symposium by another you could consider
them a great philosopher epinasty wrote
the fakeness ocean surface time
there's an adult anybody philosophers at
the dinner table did you read that in
one of your classes here okay it's been
about five years and I haven't done
anything with it so it's kind of like a
refresher course in philosophy
usually it's just culinary and it's you
know a lot of discussions happening it's
more oriented towards okay yeah we know
about some other drinking party and
table conversation from a few other
texts like like Cicero or Diogenes rare
case and then the person who time and
the symposiums way he has these
characters doing a symposium kind of
thing and talking it's very self
referential we're talking about the
nature of symposium probably this is
much much later later work so any any
questions about the literary right by
the way I highly recommended
we
okay so one of the key themes that I
think you can identify in looking at
Plato and Xenophon Butare here's what we
can hold is a woodchuck this is somebody
you can call moderation and enjoy loot
our talks about this the most the idea
you know for example we talked about the
not quite master ceremonies a master
drink having to be a certain kind of
character you don't want somebody who's
too strict because they won't give
anybody the wine that they're right you
don't want somebody who's too lenient
because they let everybody get too drunk
and what's wrong with why not let
everybody drink as much as they want
well there's other things that work in
order to have a really good time I think
about some of the times you've gone out
with friends to the bar are the best
times that you've ever had the laundry
who's got weekly drunk and can't
remember anything
and maybe woke up in the car you know
what are the other times we drank some
and you ran into some really interesting
people and we had some conversations and
some really fun things came out of them
that's what they were aiming so they
wanted to try to have certain like a
broad spectrum of enjoyment
if you indulge in any one element too
much you're gonna screw up the other
ones so you don't wanna get too drunk
but you want to drink enough that your
bothers you you want to be able to joke
with you that's an important part of it
you see that in Xenophon you see that in
Plato Plutarch you know he gives rules
tends to do or just what kind of joking
should be permissible and how much of it
should go on and what kind of people
seat next to each other because they
won't be able to take a joke and if you
think about that this does make good
sense you don't want you don't want it
to be totally humorous right but you
don't want people bullying there's a
debate in Xenophon's whether they should
introduce perfumes sensual enjoyment of
odor and Socrates says no we got to draw
the line we've already got the drinking
we've got the spectacle we've got the
music we've got the conversation we
don't need to smell anything the smells
we've got our heart and there's so
there's this entire idea of running
through it we ought to be somewhat
rational in how we unwind how we
get away from purely you know work
rational utilitarian stuff over here we
don't want to just to generate into the
contrary because that's not gonna be
smart
what do you guys think about this thing
at all
nothing over them
gaudí
well they'd have entertainment so
everything in Plato's they send away the
future because they they're gonna pocket
on top of the stack in Zen of funds they
have these dancers movies from what we
have in the description pretty
incredible that would be part of
actually though the guy who's in charge
of the dancing gets mad at Socrates
Cassandra Jesus talking while he's tried
to do his show we care about that music
tries to get one over on him and that
husband
the magic with with the property
they are any other questions or comments
about that
so think about where we are today we're
having our own little this is not quite
a symposium because I'm giving a long
speech but we are getting the drink and
maybe we'll have some conversation about
this afterwards why are academic affairs
so lacking
spectacles music joking either yeah
dry stodgy snyder education equity
worldwide culture wide or is this
or greater extremes and America versus
other cultures good question I'm not
really well with to study yeah
either ascetic or complete you know
there was much more of a sense
you know 35 straight hours
and the pedicab cops you brought in
light and cheese and we talked about
what we
we have intercourse and it was
and everyone else that was
like well this really
we can do this
breaking bread and talking to one
another
but you knew would do that in graduate
school after yeah junior I believe there
is towards the end of the year and
professors like there have been grab
your stuff we're walking with the bar
down the street that's where having fun
so I know it really does I went to a
very liberal Performing Arts
yeah we would do those things probably
not it you know but some professors you
know like that but no and nobody got
wasted or anything lot of people
pitchers and we sat on had class like we
normally would so one of the big
problems would be either well the higher
level class - yeah that could
I think what I do you know even when it
comes to the Dalton when exactly mirrors
one of the things so historically one of
the things that happened is having fun
screwing around we have to put it way up
here so they idealize it and then all
these other elements kind of process if
you want to do this moderation of
enjoyment you need a certain kind of
person you do and I think over time a
lot of people have become distrustful
and maybe academics reputable business
because of their behavior just letting
people enjoy themselves while we're
talking about some sort of complex
intellectual
well we go to the bar and we talk about
it everyone's just gonna be watching the
TV yelling at each other or flirting
whatever else you like
one of the things I like
imbibe as
participating in libation
Oh
today's event you know coming together
building a fire which is very kind of
primal aqui
yeah
together and having it not be something
that's you know in front of the
whiteboard or a blackboard or you know
it's just it's nice to be able to do
that but sometimes it's the paint you
know I think you of that
project project and we forget how this
type of IQ do I really learning any
yeah being having conversations about
topics not just figuring out you know do
I need to take these funny
remember that we're playing really good
the good thing is though in today's
world I think it's also becoming
complementary because I know that if I
go to like to go we go to give a paper
and a conference somewhere will turn
after right it doesn't matter if I hear
any of the other papers
I pick up the people who I want to get
to know people who are maybe Bob because
you're an experienced conference go
well that's what you have to do
otherwise you come rod Yeah right though
I was right
it was then and then feel like you've
missed out great I was at a conference
in Spain a few years ago they had they
were all ten-minute papers and they had
a hundred papers a day in the one venue
right but the bar was outside the door
to venue home
oh so you opened the door of the lecture
theatre and the bar was right the 20th
yeah
and they were still going to they talk
at night there was five people listening
to the lecture booze hook two hundred
people in the bar you know but the
people in the bar were doing more
business than the guys didn't let you
yeah it's very much come right you need
both you need to you need to pull of the
stodgy this and the academic atmosphere
to get people there and then the
informality to get them talking point